from Lady Gaga's emotional acceptance
speech to doubling up on wins et is
taking a look at a few of the standout
moments from the 24th annual Critics
Choice Awards and the Critics Choice is
it's a tie a list ladies shared the
stage with not one but two ties of the
night
crazy crazy we got a tie both Amy Adams
and Patricia Arquette won for Best
Actress in a movie made for TV or
limited series while Lady Gaga and Glenn
Close took home the Best Actress Award
for their work in the wife and a star is
born
Gaga couldn't help but hold back tears
as she thanked her love fiance Christian
Kirino and co-star Bradley Cooper Thank
You Christian my love and kept going
like a true star when they tried to cut
her off it's okay I can still do this
with a piano background how are you
balancing at all a casual Vegas
residency with award season campaigning
oh my god you know it's a lot of hard
work
but I have a wonderful team and we love
what we do and it's it's been amazing I
get to celebrate you know the art of so
many of my peers and then I also get to
sing my pop show in Vegas and then I
have a jazz show as well which I love I
love to sing jab so I'm enjoying crazy
rich Asians cast was overwhelmed with
excitement as they took home the Critics
Choice Award for Best Comedy I mean it's
gonna be hard to top the best of them so
yeah I mean I don't know what they're
gonna do how can they make it bigger
bigger and crazier
and although rami malek and nicole
kidman did not meet back on stage after
their hilariously awkward moment from
the Globes et was with the pair on the
red carpet ahead of Critics Choice where
the longtime friends laughed off the
viral moment Nicole Kidman are you guys
gonna make up for that viral moment
tonight where we get another interaction
because the best did we
having a laugh about it together she's
she's another one I've admired for so
many years we're really good friends so
that's why I just did not feel his hand
on my back I was mortified that so no I
loved that man and he's so gentle and
softly spoken he's it darling
[Music]